friday night jack dorsey sent the tweet
heard round the world he explicitly went
out and said the one word that people in
the developing nations always shy away
from he tweeted and said hyperinflation
is going to change everything it's
happening now jack dorsey is not just an
average person on twitter he's the
founder and ceo of the business he also
is the founder and ceo of square 100
plus billion dollar financial firm and
so for him to utter the words inflation
hyperinflation people get real
uncomfortable but
let's dig into exactly what he's talking
about so in the replies we saw somebody
say yep we live with this built into our
mental models in nigeria inflation is
currently 16
in nigeria and jack said it will happen
in the united states soon and so the
world he's specifically referring to the
fact that the united states dollar is
global reserve currency then somebody
said hyperinflation is a currency
collapse worst possible outcome for most
be careful what you wish for and jack
says not a wish nor do i think it's a
positive at all so jack's obviously very
clear one in understanding what
inflation is what hyperinflation is two
that it's bad that we shouldn't wish for
it and also understand that there's
other places around the world that have
high levels of inflation and he is
basically saying that it's starting to
happen here in the united states now as
you would expect all of the
mainstream puppets they just came
running out of the woodwork oh look it's
a tech pro he tweeted about
hyperinflation what does he know let's
just go dunk on them and so here's a
couple of people who i think their
tweets won't necessarily end up
very well idiots literally run
everything yes jack dorsey the one of
the best entrepreneurs of our lifetime
who has built two multi-billion dollar
companies is an idiot correct great job
vincent then if we look at robin's
wigglesworth literally one of the
absolute worst mainstream financial
analysts and reporters when it comes to
any of this stuff said strong contender
for macro tourist of the century gong
well jack dorsey probably understands
this stuff better than robin and then we
have david larder who says
hyperinflation is not happening put the
bong down
right and then we also have oliver
rennick who probably well i'm not gonna
say it but uh it works at td ameritrade
as a journalist and uh is questionable
at best so nice to see jack finally out
himself as a huckster
okay
uh then we have virginia this was the
grand champion the person who by far had
the absolute best uh stupid tweet said
like divorce in a marriage this word
jack tweeted should not be uttered
unless you're trying to bring it into
being no one should take investment
advice from someone who sees himself as
making markets how insanely reckless to
tweet this immoral jack ban thyself
so literally the mainstream puppets all
calling for the censorship of jack
dorsey because he said hyperinflation is
going to change everything and it's
happening but virginia of course she
couldn't take the crown steve hanke who
is undefeated in stupid takes he decided
to come over the top off the top rope
360 windmill dunk there have been 62
certified hyperinflations in world
history at present no countries
experiencing hyperinflation jack should
know better than to tweet irresponsible
public statements now what steve is
specifically referring to is the exact
definition
of hyperinflation is 50
month-over-month inflation that
qualifies as hyperinflation so if you're
at 48 month over month inflation you
don't count as hyperinflation but if
you're at 50 it counts it doesn't matter
how bad the situation is it doesn't
matter if people on the ground can't
afford food if they're willing to take
to the streets in protest in an attempt
to overthrow a central bank or a
government like we see happening in the
last couple of weeks and multiple places
around the world that doesn't count as
hyperinflation because steve henke said
it doesn't meet
50 month-over-month inflation so the
measurement of hyperinflation is stupid
because some academics just came up with
a random number back in a classroom
somewhere and they said this is the only
way that it categorizes as
hyperinflation but ultimately
hyperinflation when people refer to that
what they are referring to is run away
high inflation if you live in a country
that has 10 percent month over month in
fl inflation you're trying to leave
you're out you're trying to escape that
is a really bad situation
whether it is 10 month over month or 50
it's really bad i would argue even two
or three percent month-over-month
inflation is really bad and you would be
trying to escape and so of course
michael saylor the adult in the room
stepped in and said inflation is the
problem bitcoin is the solution now when
we start to actually look at this let's
first start with what exactly are the
official numbers the numbers that all of
the mainstream puppets all point to and
say oh look we don't have hyperinflation
we just have 5.4 inflation so first we
can look at the federal reserve's money
supply the m2 absolute rocket ship up
and to the right no end in sight they
can't stop they can't bring it down
literally we are just going to go off
like a rocket ship then when we look at
price inflation for all items since 1913
what we see
is that it appears like inflation has
actually come down over time it's gotten
better congratulations amazing well as
with most things in the world it's not
because you're comparing apples to
apples they keep changing the definition
of the cpi inflation they literally are
manipulating the data in order to show
you a lower number and to trick people
into believing that the true inflation
number is not as high as it is don't
believe me this is a direct quote out of
an investopedia article that clearly
outlines exactly what the controversy is
originally the cpi was determined by
comparing the price of a fixed basket of
goods and services spanning two
different periods
in this case the cpi was a cost of goods
index so we would look at what is the
change in the cost of these goods
however over time congress embraced the
view that cpi should reflect changes in
the cost to maintain a constant standard
of living so consequently the cpi has
evolved into a cost of living index it's
different than a cost of goods index
over the years the methodology used to
calculate the cpi has undergone numerous
revisions according to the bls the
changes removed biases that caused the
cpi to overstate the inflation rate so
the people who are incentivized to have
inflation lower said oh we're
overstating it and so we're to
remove bias and so we're going to change
the way that we count the new
methodology takes into account changes
in the quality of goods and substitution
substitution the change in purchases by
consumers in a response to price changes
changes the relative weighting of the
goods in the basket that ladies and
gentlemen is manipulation they're
literally switching things in and out in
an effort to show you a lower inflation
rate the overall result tends to be a
lower cpi exactly what we're talking
about however critics view the
methodological changes and the switch
from a cost of goods index to a cost of
living index as a purposeful
manipulation that allows the us
government to report a lower cpi
now this ultimately gets at the crux of
it if you remember in a previous episode
we talked about the fact that the cpi
rent index shows a two percent
year-over-year change in rents
i dare one of you to go and find me
places in the united states where it is
less than two percent two percent is
supposed to be the national average of
the change in rent
that's not happening
actually
zillow shows almost nine or ten percent
change in rents apartment.com shows 13
or 14 percent change in rents year over
year so how is it that the private
companies that have points up to a
hundred million data points in real time
are showing us anywhere between 8 to 14
change year over year but the government
statistics that are based on the 1990
census data are telling us that
inflation is actually just under 2 when
it comes to rents it doesn't make sense
they don't have good data sets and they
don't have proper methodology to
actually calculate this now that brings
us back to jack dorsey and twitter and
square twitter has nothing to do with
inflation
nobody's claiming that jack dorsey as
ceo and founder of twitter knows
anything about inflation
but jack dorsey the co-founder and ceo
of square 100 plus billion dollar
financial firm that may have the most
robust and accurate real-time data set
in the world on what the united states
inflation number is we should probably
be listening now what do i mean that
square has the most robust real-time
accurate data set well let's look at
square's product suite
square has a number of products you may
not be aware of first they have the
reader where they are physical devices
that allow mobile phones to process
payments they then have square register
right at the point of sale for many
merchants they have virtual gift cards
they also have cash app which is a
consumer mobile app for banking services
and investing more than 30 million
monthly active users on cash app they
also have square capital which is
financing to merchants they have square
payroll literally they process the
payroll of multiple companies they have
square financial services which is a
bank charter they also have credit karma
tax which has been integrated into cash
app and then they just acquired after
pay which now is getting them into the
buy now pay later game with over a
hundred thousand merchants in various
countries
when you start to look at this square
not only sees the actual real-time data
at the point of sale
what was this business at their register
selling this good for last year what are
they selling it for now there's no i
call them and ask them there's no i hope
they're reporting the right number it is
the absolute truth it's at the register
they literally own the data at the
register they know exactly what that
item or that sku was selling for last
year and they know what it is selling
now
on top of that they also have 30 million
monthly active users on cash app some of
that is just for peer-to-peer
transactions where they're sending money
back and forth to each other but also
they have about seven million people who
use the cash card it's literally a debit
card where they can see all of the
purchase data
on top of that they have square payroll
where they can see hey what was this
employee being paid by this company last
year and what are they being paid now
there is no reporting there is no i call
and i ask there is no waiting for your
tax returns it is real-time robust data
set and so i don't know what the data
says but neither does anybody else but
if the ceo of a company that is sitting
on this specific data set is telling us
that there are higher levels of
inflation than what the official numbers
are reporting
rather than trying to dunk on him on the
internet and rather than trying to label
him an idiot or saying that he's simply
a macro tourist of the century maybe we
should listen
and that's the problem with discourse in
2021 is that it can't possibly be true
in the eyes of the establishment that
actually the guy who has a technology
company who sits
on top of the most robust accurate
real-time data set probably in the
country
he possibly couldn't know what he's
talking about because the reporters they
believe that the cpi metric is real
because the government is coming to save
them